nunchuck skills ball hunting skills
computer hacking skills girls only want
boyfriends who have great skills Oh
[Music]
question hi my hardwood five-foot-ten
reading for the part of Miranda Priestly
is there some reason my coffee isn't
here is there some reason my coffee is
it here is she sick or something
hi I'm Jermaine Fowler I'll be reading
for Miranda Priestly for its Devil Wears
Prada flow for spring how groundbreaking
no no no no that wasn't a question
the next line um that's all so unique
like you need that without it you don't
have any real I don't I love that word
thank you
nunchuck skills bow hunting skills and
computer hacking skills girls only want
boyfriends who have great skills
hey I'm Jermaine Fowler I am reading
forward Napoleon Napoleon Dynamite hey I
see you drinking 1% does that mean you
think you're fat cuz you're not you
could you you could be drinking whole if
you want it to okay
next side nunchuck skills bow hunting
skills computer hacking skills girls
only want boyfriends who have great
skills oh it's a liger it's pretty much
my favorite animal it's like a tiger and
a lion mixed its bred for its skills in
magic Tina you fat Lord come give me
some dinner it's butter a carb Oh hardly
again five foot ten reading for the part
of Regina George
it's Mean Girls one of my favorite
movies I just thought I would add that
get in loser we're going shopping why do
you wear your hair like that your hair
looks so sexy push back Katie can you
tell him his hair looks sexy when it's
pushed back get in loser we're going
shopping
Jason you do not come to a party at my
house with Gretchen and then scam on
some poor innocent girl right in front
of us three days later so you can go
shave your back now wait is butter
[Music]
Jason you do not come to a party at my
house with Gretchen and then scam on
some poor innocent girl right in front
of us three days later so you can go
shave your back now hmm what was that I
felt real it's all right it's all good
did I get this did I get
[Music]